there is something to be said for the  athlete mindset approach to creative  pursuits  we look at creative pursuits as like  these unpredictable you know realms in  which  you know not always the best people  succeed and some people who are less  deserving are rewarded like it's very  much not a meritocracy but there are  things that you could do  to put yourself in a position to succeed  when that moment arises yes but i do  think that every artist has to face a  moment probably every athlete too  where you ask yourself  are you interested in this goal or are  you committed and that's that's a big  difference  if you  are merely interested in a goal you're  going to find the reasons why it wasn't  possible for you or you're gonna you're  gonna back out when it when it hurts or  when it you get one no  and if you're committed then you will  keep showing up